Welcome back. So, let us continue our discussion where we stopped. So, we understand that we
need to look at the purity, we need to look at several other factors to decide when to
stop growing the tree. In general, one of the things as I was mentioning that we always
aim to avoid overfitting in decision trees and I mean what is desired is that we want
a decision tree that is not very big in size yet that fits the training data reasonably
well. So, this is an ideal compromise or ideal kind of tradeoff we want that we do not want
a decision tree which is like very large, very deep, but we also want it to fit the
training data properly. One extreme example of a simple decision tree is called decision
stump where we only test the value of a single feature.
So, just think that it just have like just one root node and the corresponding rule
and the leaf nodes. So, that is the simplest version of decision tree. It is also called
decision stump because this is not necessarily a tree, but this is not very powerful because
it cannot generalize. Just think that you have 4 features, but you are just using only
one feature to construct the decision stump. But what happens is that like we are going
to discuss the ensemble of trees later in case of large ensemble where we are kind of
combining a lot of decision stumps together. So, that can make a difference, but a single
decision stump is not very powerful. On the other hand, let us say you have started
building a tree, the tree have become very large and you are growing it, growing it,
growing it. Now, at certain point you may also want to prune the tree. So, that means
that you may want to cut the tree so that the resultant tree becomes a little less complex
and more general. Now, one option is that while you are building the tree you stop,
you do not build it to become very complex. So, that is like pruning while you are building
the tree. The other option is that you prune after you have built the tree. So, this is
kind of like a post pruning routine that. So, this is also called a post pruning because
then already the tree has been built and you are trying to cut down the tree. So, then
the question is like similar to the question like which node we should select, which feature
we should select to grow the tree. Similarly, we have to judge which nodes to select when
we are pruning the tree. So, for this again cross validation can be used like where we
use our validation set which is separate from the training set and we prune every possible
node that does not hurt the accuracy on the validation set. So, it is kind of like we
prune one particular node, we see whether what is the accuracy and with every pruning
we go ahead if the accuracy is not hurt. The other option is to greedily remove the node
that improves the validation accuracy the most. So, suppose one option is that you are getting
certain accuracy. Let us say you are getting 80 percent accuracy and you prune if the accuracy
do not go less than 80 percent. The other thing is that you prune when you see that
the accuracy has improved from 80 percent to 85 percent or 82 percent to 83 percent.
So, to summarize all the discussions which we had around decision tree, decision tree
is generally very simple and easy to interpret. They can easily handle different types of
features like we looked at categorical features, it can take real numerical features, decision
trees are very fast at times of testing because you only need to compare like you compare
the rule at the root node, you compare the rule at the internal node, essentially if
h is the height of the tree you just make h comparisons which is much better compared
to let us say k nearest neighbor where to just find the k nearest neighbors you will have
to compare with all possible like you have to make an all possible all pair comparison.
The fourth point is that multiple decision trees can be combined via ensemble methods
to make a very more or make more powerful model for example, random forest. So, we are
again going to see this just in like couple of slides how multiple decision trees can
be merged together can be combined together to make up a addition.
So, these are all good things about decision trees, but there are also certain weaknesses
of decision trees. For example, learning the best possible decision tree is a computationally
hard problem. So, there you cannot guarantee that given a training data I have built the
best possible tree because all the algorithms which we have discussed they all are some
kind of greedy heuristic based algorithm. Sometimes the decision trees can grow large
and can become very complex tend to overfit unless we early stop or we apply some pruning
post post the tree is built. So, now let us look at ensemble classifier.
So, so far knife base k nearest neighbor support vector machine decision tree they all were
a single classifier. So, when I say single classifier you are building a single model
which can classify a particular trace input. Now, we are going to talk about classific
classifier models where essentially a decision is being made by multiple classifiers together
not a single classifier. So, what are the benefits of this? So, essentially we can have
multiple classifiers at work where every classifier conduct classification on the same set of class
level, but they may use different input or may have different parameters. They may even
produce different output for a certain example. So, just think of a scenario that let us say
often time like in industry or even in academia where we will have to take a very important
decision we form a committee rather than relying on one individual to apply their knowledge
and decide on the behalf of a large organization. Because one individual may have may be very
smart very intelligent, but they may have certain limitation they may not be able to
see all possible combinations of facts. They may not be able to foresee what can be the
impact of the decision they are taking now. Instead of that if you form a committee with
let us say 5 people each 5 people can look at a problem from 5 different different viewpoints.
At the same time they may have very complementary skill set like some committee some member
of the committee may look at it from a financial viewpoint that what is going to be the financial
implication of this particular decision some person may actually be looking at it from
a personal or personal kind of point of view that what is going to be the impact of the
current manpower which is there in the organization.
So, different people may come with like different background and they can look at the same problem
with different set of eyes. So, often time if you take a collective decision after discussing
within the committee which have considered all these different aspects the decision turns
out to be much better than if it was taken by one single individual. The same thing is
true for ensembles that when you are looking at a single classification algorithm like
decision tree it is just a single model which is making the decision. On the other hand
if you can merge multiple classifiers each of them are looking at different aspects of
the data and accordingly they are taking some decision and then the goal is to make sure
that you combine the decision in a good way.
Now, to achieve very good output from this ensembling ideally what we want is we want
to learn different classifiers which look at different training examples so that they do
not get biased by looking at the same data point. Similarly, another option is that you
allow the one classifier to look at only a subset of features not all features and different
classifiers look at some separate subset. So, this way you can ensure that you have
a wide variety or diversity in the amount of data or the type of data different classifiers
are seeing and typically this method tends to yield very good output.
Now, in terms of performance it may happen that each of the classifiers the individual
classifiers are not perfect in fact they may not be like very suitable compared to some
other classifiers. But if they are complementary if they have some complementary skill set
for example like where the training data points which are correctly classified by one classifier
is not correctly classified by other classifier then you get the complementary inbuilt in
the ensembling process. So, that way it can actually lead to much improvement so it can
utilize this complementary property to offer potential improvement.
Now, the whole problem boils down to ensemble learning. Learning this ensembling method
one how to create classifiers with complementary performances and how to conduct voting or
how to conduct the aggregation when different classifiers are giving different prediction
for the same test input. In fact, in this context one particular term is often used
is called strong learner versus weak learner. A strong learner is a model which look at
level training data and they produce a classifier which can be arbitrarily accurate. So, that
means which you can make it like very very very complex which can become very accurate
but in turn it can be a very complex model. On the other hand weak learners look at the
same level data for training but they may produce a classifier which is not very complex
which is not very powerful but which is of course more accurate than random guessing.
Ensembling is often to combine or boost weak learners to create a very strong learner alright.
So, the idea we have an ensemble often is to derive a strong learner from a collection
of weak learners. So, in this lecture we are going to talk about three different process
of ensembles or approaches of ensembles one is called bagging. Bagging is the short form
of bootstrap aggregating, boosting and finally random forest.
So, for bagging algorithm let us say we have training data from X1, Y1, X2, Y2, X3, Y3
all the way up to XNYN. Now we are creating a bootstrap sample. The bootstrap sample means
this is a small sample of the training data and we build a model which is maybe a weak
learner based on this small sample data. So, if you look at this particular equation
let us say we are trying to create M models or M weak learners. So, for that we are creating
M bootstrap samples from the training data. Each sample is let us say we call us like
dm and we build a model gmx from the bootstrap data dm.
So, let us say one, so if we look at an example like let us say X1, Y1, X2, Y2, X3, Y3, X4,
Y4, X5, Y5 and let us say we are going to create 3, so M is equal to 3. So, we are going
to create 3 bootstrap samples and train 3 different classifier. The first bootstrap
sample may be X1, Y1, X2, Y2. The second bootstrap example may be X2, Y2, X3, Y3, X4, Y4 and
the third may be X4, Y4 and X5, Y5. So, you see that in this case it is not guaranteed
that every bootstrap sample will have exactly the same size. Similarly, they can have overlap.
So, it is not that if you take one particular it is not like a partitioning like where
you can only take one example or one data point part of one bootstrap sample. So, multiple
bootstrap samples can have the same data point as it is in its collection. But then using
this bootstrap sample, so let us say this is D1, this is D2, this is D3, you train 3
different models G1, G2, G3 using this bootstrap data.
Now, once this models are trained then we can either just take a simple average of the
model output for regression problems and for classification problem we can compute a voting
either let us say majority voting that depending on what the majority of the models are telling
you pick the output from I mean the majority output from that or you can even have weighted
voting which we will talk later. Now, one important thing about bagging or bootstrap
aggregating is that the bootstrap sample of any instances are obtained by drawing in
examples at random with replacement. So, as I mentioned this ensures that there can be
also overlap between two bootstrap samples. Now, on average every bootstrap sample has
63 percent of the instances. So, this actually encourage predictors to have uncorrelated
error. So, that means every predictor will have some examples which are new and which
are not seen by other predictors. So, this is bagging. Now, let us come to the next
ensemble method called boosting. So, in case of boosting we want to construct weak classifiers
or weak learners using different data distribution. So, we first start with uniform waiting. So,
we put every sample in the distribution uniform weight and it can be selected from like uniform
weight then every step of learning we increase the weights of the examples which are not
correctly learned by the weak learner. So, how to increase the weight essentially you
can think of kind of repeating this example in the sample data set.
So, for instance let us say you have x 1 y 1 x 2 y 2 x 3 y 3 initially all the examples
are treated equally, but let us say in the first phase you see that you are making error
on x 2 y 2. So, in that case in the training example you repeat x 2 y 2 multiple times.
So, that way you are giving more weight to x 2 y 2. On the other hand if let us say some
examples after you have given higher weight it is starting to perform better. So, in that
case you can decrease the weight for those examples which are correctly learned by the
weak learner. So, here the idea is that you want to focus
on difficult examples which are not correctly classified in the previous step and increasingly
you want to build the classifiers in increasing steps. So, this is something like this that
initially you started with all training samples you build the first classifier then for the
second classifier you change the weight depending on where you perform poorly then again in
the next step you change the weight again and so on and finally you get the final classifier
using a weighted combination of all the classifier decisions.
So, how to combine this weak classifier decisions? So, as I mentioned like you can either have
a simple straight majority voting or you can have weighted voting where you can construct
the strong classifier by weighted voting of weak classifiers and the idea is that if you
have a better weak classifier that should get a larger weight and you iteratively add
weak classifier and you increase the accuracy of the combined classifier.
So, let us just look at one example that if you have a single learner which is trying
to differentiate between let us say blue sample and green sample you can have a single learner
which classify like this and the combined classifier let us say initially it also follows the single
learner. So, it is the same classification then we figured out that some cases it is
not doing correct. So, if you look at this here for this example it was it made a mistake.
So, all these green examples were correctly classified this blue ones were correctly classified
but this green one was not classified properly. So, then I increase the weight of this and
I try learning another classifier. Let us say the new classifier is like this now. So,
in this case the combined classifier will look something like this, but again we are
making further mistake. So, some cases we made more mistakes some cases we did not make
mistake. So, accordingly we change the weight. So, if you can look at the the animation like
each individual points now the weight is kind of changing and that is giving us another
classifier. So, in result like the combined classifier is becoming something like this
like which now correctly classifies all the blue points and all the green points. Now,
let us come to the last type of ensembling method which is called random forest.
Now, we have a single data set right like we have a single training data set. Now, how
do we obtain all these week learners? Let us say if our week learners are decision trees.
So, how do we create slightly different trees from the same data set? So, one option is
bagging where we pick the random subsets of data points from the training set to create
n smaller data sets and we fit a decision tree on every subset. So, this is called bagging.
The other option is instead of taking a random subset of data points we take a random subset
of the features and then fit different decision trees by constraining every decision tree
to operate only on a random subset of features. So, let us just look at this example to make
this point more clear. So, let us say these are our training set where we have apples
and oranges. Now, in the in bagging we create n subsets with examples. So, these examples
like we have some apples and some orange. Now, see you actually now build run a decision
tree learning algorithm and you come up with a decision tree which divides the whole space
into these two types. Similarly, now you have another subset of
examples and that can lead to another division of the space. So, actually although you started
with the same training set you see just because you picked like different training set or
different like bootstrap sample for individual dynamic decision tree learning algorithm.
You ended up having different ways to kind of separate out the whole space or the decision
boundaries were taking different shapes. So, this is the beauty of bagging that we started
with the same data, but in this process we ended up having a very like instantly generalizable
classification algorithm because we got so many different diverse types of decision boundaries
at the end. Now, when we are trying to test a sample.
So, this is a test example we immediately depending on the boundary which each decision
tree has created it fills I mean it kind of falls under like some area. So, let us say
this test example here this is falling mostly in the green zone and a little bit part in
the yellow zone. So, this is falling fully in the green zone, this is falling mostly
in the yellow zone and this is falling mostly in the green zone. Now, if you take a majority
vote in this case where 3 out of 4 weak learners are going to predict apple and 1 is going
to predict orange you are going to pick the final output as apple with 75 percent confidence.
So, this is how bagging works at inference time and in case of the random subspace method
or feature bagging. So, here everyone is using the same number of test example training example.
So, we are not taking any sample from the training example, but we are now looking at
different features. So, here we are looking at the mass and color, here we are looking
at the pH value and the texture, here we are looking at the pH value and the mass and based
on these different features we are creating different decision tree, we are applying different
decision tree learning algorithm to create like different decision boundaries and again
at a time when a test sample comes you again see where it falls on and depending on that
you predict like different outcome and after taking a voting you predict the final outcome
with certain confidence.
So, the difference between bagging and this random subspace method is in case of bagging
the training data was getting split into multiple small samples while in case of random subspace
method. So, the training data remains the same across different classifiers, but the features
are different. So, the features which each individual classifiers are taking are different.
So, it is resulting in a little different decision boundaries.
Now, in case of random forest it actually combines all this. So, it first it looks at
bagging like it kind of also apply this sampling or sampling of the training data set to create
like bootstrap samples to train a decision tree algorithm. It also look at the random
subspace method by taking random features it is kind of a best of both. So, where you
both do a feature bagging as well as you do a sample bagging and then you build different
decision trees based on different training data example different test data example sorry
different training data example different feature set and then finally, out of all the
weak learners which are out there you run a voting method and then you pick the final
decision based on the individual weak learner decisions and running voting on top of that.
So, to summarize bagging trains multiple instances of the same model on different data subset
and combine their prediction. Random forest extends bagging by introducing additional
randomness in feature selection for every tree enhancing the model diversity and reducing
overfitting boosting iteratively trains models by focusing on error and adjusting ways to
correct misclassified instances and enhance overall accuracy. Ensemble methods significantly
enhance performance compared to single methods like decision tree.
So, with this let me end this particular session and I would be happy to answer if there are
any questions. Yeah, so in that example yes as I mentioned like I created a little confusion.
So, in fact the same rule x1 greater than 3.5 works the left side it takes no the right
side takes ES I was just reading it the opposite. So, that is why the confusion came, but you
are right if the left side is no it works. So, thanks a lot for joining today. I hope
you got to learn different supervised learning algorithms we have covered multiple algorithms
including like single classification models like SVM, nearest neighbors, knife base and
decision tree. We have also covered algorithms which talk about ensembling of different classifiers
like bagging, boosting and decision random forest. I hope this two sessions were useful.
If you have any further questions feel free to post and we will be happy the team will
be happy to get back to you with the answers. Thanks a lot.